hey david i'm looking at the electoral
map
and it just doesn't seem like trump can
win is it even
possible for trump to get 270 electoral
votes at this point
yes yes yes yes yes do not for a
fraction of a second
think that there is not a path to
victory for donald trump there is a path
to victory for donald trump now i
understand the thought process
if you start with the 2016 map and you
look at
wow trump lost the popular vote by 3
million
and it was really one of the narrowest
scenarios where you could lose
nationally by 3 million and win
electorally and the reason trump won was
because of three states
michigan trump won by like 0.2
it was like 10 000 vote margin in
michigan um
in pennsylvania trump won by under one
point
and in wisconsin trump won by under one
point it was only about twenty three
thousand votes twenty two thousand
something votes
in wisconsin so when you look at that
and you say well okay that's how it was
in 2016
trump's losing wisconsin he's losing
michigan
he's losing arizona which he won he's
losing florida which he won
he's only winning by one in georgia he's
only winning by two in texas
north carolina is basically a tie ohio
is basically a tie
iowa's barely in the trump camp right so
when you look at it you just say
biden's gonna flip something biden's
gonna flip something and then
immediately
the map becomes very difficult for
donald trump
do not fall into that line of thinking
it is
very much the case that donald trump has
a small margin of error
he can't afford to lose very much and
still win
and i think it's important to remember
how traumatized we are
by 2016 and that may make some of us
find paths for trump in order to not get
a false sense of security
you don't need to concoct anything
outrageous what you have to remember
is donald trump is a desperate cornered
animal
we learned earlier this week that don jr
reportedly
fears that if trump loses
they all get prosecuted and indicted so
trump is fighting not only for his
political life here but he's
fighting at least as done as far as don
jr thinks
to keep himself out of court potentially
for the next
however many years uh he lives quite
frankly i don't necessarily believe that
but if you believe don jr believes it
they are acting out of desperation so
they're going to do post office
they're going to do voter suppression
they're going to allow foreign meddling
which they've never tried to stop
bill after bill after bill over the last
four years mitch mcconnell does nothing
with it
trump never talks about you know okay
you get it um
purging voter rolls they're gonna do all
of it
so i get it you look at the map from
2016 and you go well if
you just flip florida i mean it's
already looking bad for trump if you
just flip wisconsin and pennsylvania
it's bad
i get it do not we don't need to pretend
that trump is winning by a lot right now
we just need to understand
that you could again have joe biden win
maybe
biden wins instead of by 3 million votes
by 4 million votes
but that extra million comes in blue
states
and trump still pulls off an electoral
victory
that's the way we have to be thinking
and yes
donald trump very much can achieve 270
electoral votes one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you
five dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman